19:34 and a man could Sergei Kirov is
having a great day
just kidding he was shot and died his
assassin was a man called Lee indeed
Nikolaev a member of the Communist Party
who may have been acting alone he also
may have been put up to it by a certain
someone which may explain why there was
nobody guarding Kirov nobody really
knows for certain though Kirov was the
chief of the leningrad communist party
was pretty influential in the murder of
such a high-ranking official was
unprecedented and the head honcho stalin
wasn't going to let such a murder go to
waste
Starlin took charge of the investigation
personally and after having Nicolai of
shot he determined that the murder was a
part of a much larger communist party
conspiracy against him in the Soviet
Union this meant only one thing it was
time for a purge a great purge if he
will stalin accused his old rivals
Grigory Zinoviev and left commendeth of
being a part of a conspiracy against him
which was being led abroad by none other
than Trotsky Zinoviev and commendeth
were both arrested by the head of the
NKVD gam Ricky goda
they were put on trial in August 1936
found guilty and shocked interestingly
enough both sanoviv and common F despite
being innocent admitted to being part of
a conspiracy there are two probable
reasons that they confess to crimes that
they didn't commit one being that they
knew they were going to die anyway and
so they decided to preserve the party's
image the other being you know torture
stalin had you goaded demoted and
replaced with nikolai jakov who was
always up for a bit of purging over the
next year two more major trials were
held Brits or more high-ranking
officials found guilty of treason the
most famous be Mikhail Tukhachevsky the
great purge also known as the Great
Terror spread further across the USSR
factory managers military officers as
well as many mid-ranking bureaucrats and
party members were also purged in the
years following the trials purge doesn't
necessarily mean shot some were taken to
the gulags instead which was much better
Stalin and the higher-ups in the
Communist Party ordered communist
officials across the USSR to root out
traitors in any Trotskyites amongst them
unsurprisingly this led to a culture of
suspicion developing which in turn led
to people accusing each other of
harboring sympathies for Trotsky between
1937 and 1938 over 100,000 Communist
Party members were purged in over half
of the military High Command was shocked
your normal everyday Soviet citizens
weren't spared the horrors of the great
purge across two years over 650,000
people were shot and a further million
was sent to the gulags
the reason why so many were found guilty
despite the overwhelming majority not
being hardline Trotsky
was that the nkvd the secret police had
quotas to fulfill some of those rounded
up were targeted simply for complaining
or disagreeing with party policy beyond
simply targeting political dissidents
Stalin focused the nkvd on different
ethnicities they were specifically
ordered to target Germans because Hitler
as well as Ukrainians when the USSR's
borders expanded in 1939 the peoples in
those new territories were also fiercely
repress with the great emphasis on the
polish the sheer number of arrests and
executions began to take their toll on
the Soviet economy and Stalin decided
that enough was enough and that the
internal enemies had been defeated he
denounced those who had made false
accusations and in 1939 he threw Yishuv
under the proverbial bus and had him
arrested in the next year he was shocked
after this the number of accusations and
arrests declined massively but that
didn't mean that anyone felt safe and
that was how Stalin wanted it the legacy
of the purge was that it cemented
Stalin's position as the sole
totalitarian leader of the USSR the
purges removed any potential mostly
imagined rivals but in doing so they
weakened the USSR made resisting
Hitler's invasion of 1941 that much
harder I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching a special
thanks to Winston Kate wood James
Bissonnette ozark a flash Henry Robin
Adam Harvey and Skye Chappell
if you'd like to learn more about the
Stalinist era and the great purges there
are some book recommendations in the
description below